wir befinden uns hier in quedlinburg in
der innenstadt das war es dass die
straße endet sich gröbern und hieraus
vermeintlichen tötungsdelikt passiert
die polizei hat gegen 18 uhr 45 die
nachricht von den schüssen gekommen und
nach folgen sind rettungskräfte
eingetroffen die dann die eine
mittlerweile verstorbene personen
reanimiert haben und wir gehen im moment
von einem tötungsdelikt aus und
ermittelt hinsichtlich motiv und täter
es gibt bislang nur vage hinweise zu den
tätern
der täter soll dunkel gekleidet gewesen
sein unsere flüchtig in richtung des
anliegenden fox sich mit einem fahrrad
entfernt
die polizei wird im moment umfänglich
den tatort aufnehmen sie sehen im
hintergrund kollegen der kriminalpolizei
die unterstützt werden durch die
tatortgruppe des landeskriminalamtes
geworden vorhin in den
fahndungsmaßnahmen mit einem
hubschrauber über quedlinburg unterwegs
und mit kollegen des einsatzdienstes des
polizeireviers unterstützt von kollegen
der nachbar die suchen denn alle hier
schon da ist flüchtig erschossen anders
tormann ist die staatsanwaltschaft hier
alles wie soll man darüber denken ist
naja man ab ob es ein bisschen angst mir
nun zugeschaltet bild-reporter thilo
scholtyssek kilo weiß man jetzt schon
etwas über die hintergründe dieser tat
guten morgen also das wichtigste zuerst
14 stunden nach dem verbrechen gibt es
immer noch keine spur von dem täter die
verhandlung läuft gestern abend wissen
die bis zum einbruch der dunkelheit
kreiste der hubschrauber über der stadt
auch heute gehen die suchmaßnahmen
weiter was man gesichert weiß ist dass
das opfer ein rentner ist erst 73 jahre
alt und wurde hier hinter mir in der
straße grüner auf offener straße
erschossen
die spurensicherung arbeitet das tief in
die nacht hinein hat er weitere spuren
gesichert
heute morgen ging es los die polizei hat
die abfallwirtschaft bestellt damit die
glascontainer durchsucht werden können
man vermutet dass sich vielleicht die
tatwaffe darin befindet dies erreicht
man über den täter nach wie vor nur dass
er auf einem fahrrad geflüchtet ist dass
es sich um einen jüngeren menschen
ansetzt wir wissen wir haben von der
polizei erfahren dass das opfer mit
mutmaßlich drei schüssen getötet wurde
und wir haben erfahren dass die schüssel
den das opfer in den rücken der rentner
in den rücken getroffen haben sind
vielen dank thilo scholtyseck für diese
neuen erkenntnisse die fahndung läuft
noch immer du wirst uns auf dem
laufenden halten
dankeschön